[Music]
venturing into the deep sea is something
that humans were not designed for deep
water can be fatal in the obvious way
drowning but can also kill you in not so
obvious ways like decompression sickness
oxygen toxicity or complications arising
from nitrogen narcosis but as I
discussed in the last video these
complications don't come from the high
pressure of the deep alone they all
arise from breathing air under pressure
this is why the deepest scuba dive ever
recorded is only 332 meters which took
12 minutes to reach and 15 hours to
return from and the deepest saturation
dive was 701 meters the deepest a human
has ever been outside a submersible
going any deeper with current technology
becomes excessively dangerous but for
reference many offshore oil fields lie
beneath much deeper water than this and
all of them require constant maintenance
the perdido oil field lies under nearly
two thousand four hundred and fifty
meters of ocean and the oil rigs that
exist there are the world's deepest
remotely operated vehicles have to be
used for the deepest work and this is
not without its disadvantage even the
best ROV operators are no substitute for
having a human on the scene atmospheric
diving suits have been invented to try
to bridge the gap between saturation
divers and ROV s keeping the person
inside at one atmosphere of pressure but
these suits are extremely heavy hard to
maneuver and can only operate at a max
depth of around 600 meters if there was
a way to remove the limitations that
breathing air at depth imposes on the
body then humans could in theory dive
much deeper than they currently can as
deep as the deepest oil rigs maybe even
to the bottom of the Mariana Trench but
you can't remove the need to breathe
from the equation and you can't remove
the immense pressure that exists at the
bottom of the ocean but what you can
remove is the need to breathe air
if humans could breathe liquid instead
of air many of the problems that
deep-sea divers face could be completely
eliminated while the idea seems crazy
the concept is straightforward on the
surface instead of breathing oxygen-rich
air you breathe the oxygen rich liquid
as long as the alveoli and our lungs can
receive an exchange enough oxygen they
surprisingly don't care how it gets
there and in theory liquid breathing
could allow divers to go deeper than
they ever have because liquids can't be
compressed in the same way that gas can
as the diver descends with lungs full of
liquid they won't be exposed to the huge
partial pressure changes that happen
when the lungs are filled with gas as I
mentioned in the last video when
breathing normal air under pressure each
breath taken contains many more
molecules of oxygen and nitrogen than a
breath taken at the surface due to the
increased pressure and under more
pressure more and more nitrogen builds
up in the body's tissues this becomes a
problem when the diver ascends and the
nitrogen comes out of solution and
creates dangerous bubbles causing the
condition known as the bends
but with liquid in the lungs instead of
air the body would not become saturated
with nitrogen at all decompression
sickness and the long decompression
times needed to avoid it could in theory
be completely eliminated
nitrogen narcosis too could be avoided
and oxygen toxicity would not be a
problem since the level of oxygen being
delivered to the body would remain
constant but in theory is the key phrase
here it all sounds good on paper but can
this actually work in real life
it's long been a part of the sci-fi
world notably the James Cameron movie
the abyss where it plays a central role
but ultimately it's just special effects
right well for the humans it is but for
the rat that is not a special effect it
is actually breathing liquid so if the
rat can do it can we
how far off from reality is this idea
for humans the idea of liquid breathing
has been around since the 1960s where it
was first studied by the Office of Naval
Research to try to increase the escape
depth from submarines scientists
immersed mice in oxygenated saline in
pressures of up to a hundred and sixty
atmospheres which is the pressure one
mile below the surface depending on the
pressure temperature and composition of
the breathing medium the mice could
survive for several minutes and
sometimes up to several hours breathing
liquid so the concept of liquid
breathing was proven in a way but
something was still ultimately killing
the mice they could not survive
indefinitely in these experimental
conditions scientists learned that they
didn't die from too little oxygen being
delivered to their bodies as you might
guess but rather from too much carbon
dioxide remaining in it respiratory
acidosis is the condition that occurs
when the lungs can't remove enough
carbon dioxide produced by the body the
oxygenated saline solutions were not
allowing enough co2 to dissolve into it
from the lungs ultimately killing the
mice and this brings us to the first
major challenge with liquid breathing to
try to get around this problem
scientists knew that they needed to find
a liquid medium that could dissolve
large amounts of both oxygen and co2
very few liquids have this property
except for silicone oils and
perfluorocarbons or PFCs
after more experiments with mice
silicone oils proved to be toxic and
only PFCs remained as a possible
solution to the co2 problem PFC czar a
type of synthetic liquid a hydrocarbon
with the hydrogen replaced by fluorine
they are clear and odorless and
chemically and biologically inert and on
top of this they are great at carrying
oxygen and co2 chemically pfcs are an
ideal medium for carrying respiratory
gases but physically using them to
breathe is still extremely difficult in
reality and this brings us to the second
major hurdle with liquid breathing even
though they carry oxygen and co2 well
PFCs have nearly twice the density of
water which make them much more
difficult to breathe in and out than air
the lungs and diaphragm did not evolve
to push that much mass in and out the
average male lung capacity is six liters
and the average density of PFCs is 1.9
grams per milliliter which means the
diaphragm would need to push and pull
around 12 kilograms of mass with each
breath to fully inhale or exhale the
liquid so while the PFC medium may be
able to dissolve a lot of oxygen in co2
moving enough of it in and out to keep
up with the body's requirements becomes
almost impossible co2 build-up would
still be a dangerous problem especially
under any amount of exertion but
determined to push on with the
experiments the Office of Naval Research
decided that the research progressed to
the point of testing it on the first
commercial diver however while this was
an important milestone this human trial
wasn't a resounding success lying on an
operating table the diver inhaled well
oxygenated liquid and was indeed able to
breathe but afterwards he developed
pneumonia after they failed to get rid
of all of the liquid from his lungs and
this is the third major problem with
liquid breathing returning to breathing
air from liquid can be problematic or
even fatal if all of the liquid isn't
removed while all these obstacles should
be enough to put off most research some
scientists and innovators are still
trying to figure out a way to make
liquid breathing for deep-sea diving a
reality one inventor thinks he has come
up with a plan to make it possible he
proposes using a compressible chest
plate that would mechanically force
liquid in and out of the lungs along
with a co2 scrubbing device the
scrubbing device would take blood out of
the body via a catheter inserted into
the groins femoral vein then it would
circulate the blood through an
artificial Gill that would use soda-lime
to absorb the co2 before returning the
blood to the body so in theory the risk
of respiratory acidosis could be
eliminated allowing the divers to exert
themselves and work for long periods
under the sea but if having a machine
that forces liquid in and out of your
lungs by crushing your ribcage
and tubes coming out of your arteries
doesn't sound bad enough you are still
left with the final and perhaps most
horrible part of the entire idea of
breathing liquid actually breathing it
in you put on the helmet it fills with
liquid and then you have to drown
yourself in it even if you rationally
know it will be okay convincing your
brainstem of that fact is a tall order
every instinct you have will scream at
you to not breathe it in it will feel
exactly the same as regular drowning
except in the final moment in the last
desperate gasp you just don't die
no thank you it's hard to imagine any
amount of training that could allow you
to overcome the instinct of sheer panic
with all these hurdles both biological
and psychological it seems like liquid
breathing for deep-sea diving is likely
to remain a dream however all the
research that's been done has not been
for nothing
liquid breathing or liquid ventilation
as it's called in the medical field has
huge potential to treat people with a
range of lung problems premature babies
born before 28 weeks in particular can
have huge difficulties breathing often
because their lungs have not developed
enough to adjust from the liquid
environment of the womb to breathing air
in gas form their underdeveloped alveoli
lack vital surfactants which stop the
air sacs from sticking together when we
exhale to combat this doctors have begun
to use PFCs with remarkable success the
pfcs can act as a temporary surfactant
enabling gas exchange and giving the
lungs time to finish developing the
technique is now also being tested in
adults with lung injuries and as a drug
delivery mechanism for people with COPD
or cystic fibrosis the medical
applications for liquid ventilation will
help to save countless lives and as this
research progresses if an even better
oxygen and co2 carrier than pfcs is
discovered may be liquid breathing will
one day take people to the bottom of the
sea after all
I have been obsessed with underwater
exploration since I was a kid and the
fact that so much of the ocean remains
undiscovered is one of my favorite
things to get excited about and even
outside of the purely natural world
the sea has so many hidden secrets of
ancient civilizations that are waiting
to be uncovered the Black Sea in
particular is known for its
well-preserved shipwrecks which give
historians an amazing look back in time
if you like learning about discoveries
like this then you should check out the
ocean exploration documentaries on
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
streaming platform that has thousands of
high quality high budget documentaries
like this one called expeditions black
sea wrecks which is about a team of
scientists on a three-year exploration
of the black sea in search of evidence
of the ancient empires that sailed their
ships into these unknown waters and if
you're a fan of educational content and
if you're looking for more quality
things to watch during your quarantine
then this is the perfect time to sign up
because a subscription to curiosity
stream now comes with a subscription to
nebula nebula is a place where top
educational content creators like
polyphonic Wendover productions and our
other channel real engineering can
create videos freely without worrying
about the YouTube algorithm or D
monetization it's a place where we can
upload our content ad free and also
experiment with original content and new
series the original content is my
favorite part of nebula shows like real
engineering logistics of d-day series
the latest episode is about the 23,000
men who landed in Normandy on d-day by
parachute and glider so if you sign up
for curiosity stream and curiosity
stream comm slash real science you'll
get a subscription to curiosity stream
and a subscription to nebula for just
$19.99 a year by signing up you're not
just supporting this channel but all of
your favorite educational content create
thanks for watching and if you would
like to see more from me the links to my
Instagram Twitter and patreon are below
[Music]
you